Google Cloud updates if you miss any of
the mind-blowing sessions from next 2023
you're not out of luck you can still
register and view all those sessions on
demand from the comfort of your own home
or pretty much wherever you want and if
you're looking to better use some of the
cool AI tools that you learned about it
next be sure to check out our article on
prompt engineering it'll help you tailor
your natural language inputs to get the
outputs that are most accurate and most
effective for you the blog post details
six best practice tips to help you make
the most of this ever evolving
technology check out the blog for
everything that we talked about on this
week's